قالت المحتجزه الاسرائيليه السابقه في غزه
راز بن عامي ان مقتل ثلاثه محتجزين
اسرائيليين بنيران جيشهم في مدينه غزه
يؤكد ان المحتجزين على حق حين حذروا مجلس
الحرب من ان القتال قد يضر بالرهاب ودعت
عامي في تصريحات لصحيفه هارتس الاسرائيليه
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الى اقتراح اتفاق
بعوده الرهائن في غزه مشيره الى ان اهميه
اعاده الرهائن من غزه مقابل السجناء تعد
امرا عاجلا حاسما وقالت عامي التي مازال
زوجها محتجزا في غزه انها تنتظر ان تسمع
من مجلس الحرب الليله الخطوط العريضه
لصفقه تبادل وتساءلت عن الذي ينتظره مجلس
الحرب وهل ينتظر ان يتلقى ذو رهاء جثه بعد
اخرى في حين نقلت صحيفه ها ارتس عن والد
المحتجز الاسرائيلي ايتاي تشان قوله ان
مقابله الرئيس الامريكي اسهل من مقابله
مجلس
الحرب
نطالب بان يتحدث مجلس الحرب معنا الى
العائلات وانا يشرح لنا انهم ينتظرون
الحصول على عرض من الولايات المتحده او
قطر او اي جهه اخرى لا يجب على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان تكون نشطه انهم بحاجه الى
تقديم عرض على الطاوله بما في ذلك السجناء
الملطخه ايديهم بالدماء اعاده الرهائن
لم اثق ابدا بهذه الحكومه والان اصبح
الامر اسوا وقد بدانا نشعر بالذعر منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب ولكن من المخيف للغايه ان
هذه الحكومه ستقودنا جميعا الى المزيد من
الدمار والموت وانا قلق للغايه بشان
الرهائن والجنود ايضا لذا اعتقد انه يتعين
علينا الترويج لصفقه اخرى لاطلاق سراح
الرهائن
والحفاظ على سلامه المزيد من الاشخاص
ظللت اقول لمسؤولي الجيش في اسرائيل انني
افضل ان يطلق سراح اولادي من خلال
المفاوضات وليس من خلال العمليات العسكريه
لانني اخشى ان يقتلهم
الجيش